Hola buenos días los ministros de
defensa de la otan están hoy dispuestos
a enviar un claro mensaje de que se va a
ayudar a Ucrania pase lo que pase el
secretario general de la otan James tal
y como comentaba se ha pedido que son
necesarios estos sistemas de defensa
ante aérea más aún cuando hemos visto
estos recientes ataques a varios lugares
entre ellos la capital de Ucrania Aquí
es muy lejos del frente ahora mismo del
este de Ucrania por ello considera que
es más necesario que nunca de hecho
agradeció a Estados Unidos y Alemania
que esta misma semana ya ha enviado
varios sistemas de defensa durante la
reunión de hoy y mañana también se van a
abordar otras cuestiones Como por
ejemplo aumentar las municiones y
también el armamento de los propios
países aliados que han visto mermadas
Estas armas y estas municiones
justamente por la ayuda a Ucrania además
también ha habido una reunión del grupo
de contacto de apoyo a Ucrania para
saber de primera mano Cuáles son las
necesidades del país de hecho están
reunidos ahora mismo con el ministro de
defensa ucraniano
además también se abordará la protección
de las infraestructuras críticas y
sensibles muy especialmente
las últimas informaciones de un posible
también al Sabotaje en Polonia Esther
también se produce una reunión de los
ministros de energía precisamente para
atajar esta alza de los precios del gas
de cara al invierno que va a pasar en
esta reunión
Sí así es Es una reunión informal en la
capital de República Checa en Praga no
se esperan soluciones exactamente
concretas los ministros Lo que tardará
desde aunar fuerzas e intentar poner
posturas en común ahora mismo ha sido
muy difícil conseguirlo pero con un
claro objetivo hay que reducir los
altísimos precios de la electricidad y
sobre todo del gas que genera esta
electricidad la
comisaria de energía cada Simpson ha
asegurado que la comisión europea ya
está preparada para anunciar nuevas
medidas de Cara a la semana que vienen
los líderes europeos se reúnen hoy aquí
en Bruselas se reúnen la semana que
viene en Bruselas justamente para
abordar esta reducción de los precios la
comisaría de energía asegurado que habrá
propuestas por ejemplo para limitar el
precio del gas que genera electricidad
algo que vienen pidiendo al menos 15
países de la Unión Europea también de
las importaciones y además de compras
conjuntas de gas por parte de los países
el objetivo es más que nunca reducir
estos precios del gas antes de que el
invierno empiece ya aquí en la Unión
Europea y se recrudezca aún más los
precios